[Music]  i used to live my life a quarter mile at  a time  what are you smiling about dude almost  had  to say i did it but i did it  for those 10 seconds or less to make  some money  i was free  [Music]  this right here takes crazy to a whole  nother level  my family i'd ride to the death with you  but no matter how much roads behind you  you cannot run your past  and mine been a long time little brother  just caught up with me i'm gonna destroy  what you took down  there's nothing more powerful than the  lover family  you turn that into anger there's nothing  more dangerous  time to kill your family  i'm ready if you are yeah  my brother but you will never  be a family  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you